- [Woman] I would like to just read
the very last paragraph of your book.
(hip hop music)
So, yes this moment is the happiest
in my life because with every
encounter, every adventure,
every experience, ultimately,
everything always gets collectively better.
That is, it does when you
choose to focus on the positive,
which I definitely do.
You should try it.
(horns honking)
- [James] So I had my monthly
breakfast meeting with Gary.
We've been doing this religiously,
haven't missed since I been here.
A little over a year.
We covered some big topics today
including the structure
of our offices,
our UK office.
Making some big announcements.
Very excited about what 2016
brings for this office.
I told him while I've
spent time in
various marketing companies,
public relations, branding,
general market advertising,
mobile media, I've never been
part of something with
this kind of hypergrowth so
really exciting and his
his vision, inspiration and passion
is infectious to us all.
(relaxed hip hop music)
- [Matt] There's a 10:30 flight
from Dulles to London direct.
- [Gary] Oh, I like that.
I like that.
- [Matt] Gets you in at 10:40
in the morning.
- [Gary] Oh, I love that.
I love that.
- [Matt] You're not speaking
until that night.
- [Matt] Okay, cool.
- [Gary] I love that flight, yeah.
- [Matt] Also, my other thought was,
we didn't think of this, but
Passover is that Friday--
- Yeah.
- [Matt] so that allows you to get
back for Passover which
you have to get back for.
- Yes. (chuckles)
- [Matt] So cool, we're good with that.
I'll talk with DeSimone about that.
Seems like you're
feeling ok for dinner tonight.
- [Gary] I'm still holding on.
We'll see.
- [Matt] Okay.
- He's not buying any books.
I'm not asking him yet
but I'm gonna send him one.
Speaking of which, I want you
to write up a Gary VIP
right now with two items from
The Wine Room and
a P.S. my new book comes
out in a week,
by you being on this list,
I'd like to send you one.
Please reply to me.
What's going on?
What are we doing?
- [Matt] Just hang for now.
- Arlight. I need a coffee.
Where's Joe?
Bro!
- Thank you, man.
- What up, baby?
- Thank you.
- How's it going?
- It's good.
- You feeling good?
- Mhmmm. Super good.
- Good man. Good luck.
Super well.
- Yeah.
- I got invited to that
NASDAQ thing, too.
I tried to come because
I knew you were going
to be there but--
- Yeah.
- couldn't make it.
Hey!
- [Woman] Hi! How are you?
- Good to see you. How are you?
- Good!
- Rome Fortune, I'm a musician,
I'm a connector,
I am a cool dude.
Got that guy behind me,
I'mma talk some shit about him.
Some ish, you can
bleep it out, I think.
He curses on his show!
What talking about?
Gary's a mentor.
Somebody I look to, you know,
to get great ideas from.
Just somebody who's a mentor
from afar and close really.
Teaching me this jabbing
and this right hookin' shit.
You know what I'm saying?
The most important lesson
I learned from him
is probably execution.
Ideas don't mean nothing, you know?
If you have a great idea,
go do it because
the ideas exist in multiple people's heads.
You know what I'm saying?
The same idea so if you don't go do it,
somebody else is gonna do it.
- Guys great to see you.
Excited. Take care.
- [Allie] How are you?
- The best.
I was getting a ton of questions
on Twitter and my Facebook page
and so I started the show with
a real goal in mind of, one,
kind of re-entering the public
domain, you know?
From 2011 to 2014
I was pretty head
down building VaynerMedia.
I wasn't putting out a lot of content.
- [Allie] Right.
I put out Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right Hook but for the
most part I was very quiet.
And number two, more than anything,
I wanted to establish myself
as somebody who could go
to conferences and just do
Q-and-A as the keynote.
Kind of like a town hall play.
- [Allie] Right.
- Listen, I've consciously created a show
and then consciously
created a book
around this subject matter.
And the truth is, and I really
appreciate your accolades
to the book and I've
done this long enough,
this is my fourth business book,
you know, the second
and third business book
after Crush It!
Jesus. Look at the difference
in thickness between--
- [Alex] That is crazy.
- This is nuts.
- [Alex] That's crazy.
- Holy crap.
My friends, my admirers,
my contemporaries,
the people that don't
love me as much,
they, no question, were less
enthusiastic about
Thank You Economy and Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook than
what I'm feeling over the last
two weeks about #AskGaryVee.
It's very clear to me that
Q-and-A puts me and
my content in the best position
and in the world
that we now live in
I don't know if you felt this
but I've been pumped
'cause people tell me
that they're consuming the content
in a way that's sticking because
it's kind of like
boom, boom, boom.
Right, it's question, answer, question,
answer, question, answer.
It's not this drawn out chapter
where you're like,
"Wait a minute,
what did I just kind of consume?"
There's a level of
practicality to the format
that I think has been really powerful.
Allie, thank you for your time.
I wish you well.
- [Allie] Alright. Same to you.
Take care. Thank you.
- Bye-bye.
- [Allie] Buh-bye.
- That was fun.
I'm a character.
I feel like I'm a character.
I don't know what to say.
Are we dong the #AskGaryVee show?
- [DRock] No.
- [Matt] Not yet.
- Okay, what's next?
- [Matt] What's your phone at?
- My phone is at...
First, let me see Periscope.
Let me say what's up to the homies.
Sup homies?
68.
- [Matt] Cool. Can you put it
in airplane mode, please?
- Well, I'm Periscoping.
- [Matt] Once you're done Periscoping?
- Is there no Mophie in the building?
- [Matt] There is--
- Oh, I fucked up.
I should have told you
to grab the Mophie out of--
- [Matt] We have, I have one.
- Oh, cool. I'd rather
Periscope than airplane mode.
- You're going to Periscope
for the next hour?
- Matt--
- No, come on--
- Tell them you don't
want me Peris--
- No.
- Tell them. Tell them
to their face that--
- No, Periscoping right
now until #AskGaryVee.
- Check out Matt. Matt has
a blue and a brown eye.
Come on, Matt. Show them.
Show them a little love.
- Which one is it? I forget.
It's this one, right?
- Yeah. Bam.
If I had a brown and blue eye,
I would dominate DRock.
I would be bigger than I am today
because I would brand
the shit out of that.
I'd have a t-shirt with the brown,
you know what I mean?
It'd be the two colored eye,
I'd be so much bigger.
Alright, what are we doing?
- You're filming this--
- Oh, I'm filming some stuff for Fox 5.
- and then you have a meeting
and then when we get
to #AskGaryVee, we'll Periscope it.
- Alright, alright. Matt's in charge.
Sorry guys, you know. He's a bad guy.
- (Matt laughs) I'm not a bad guy.
That's bullshit.
- [Gary] When the money runs out
for your next round,
an interesting thing happens,
which is straight carnage.
I think that over the last five to seven
years we've seen way too many people
build businesses that are only
predicated on raising money
in the next round and
have no practicality.
I mean, listen, you know this.
People are raising five, ten million dollars,
it's three years later and
their business doesn't make any money.
That's stupid!
It will work, it will
work for six unicorns.
Yeah, if you build Snapchat
and Facebook and Uber,
yes, it will work.
What about for the
other 90,000 businesses?
The alternative is is what's happened
for a hundred years prior to
venture capital and technology.
Build something that has some
practicality within 24 months
and borrow money,
either from a bank or an individual
or a VC firm but go and then
make it profitable instead of
making it attractive for the next raise.
I have no empathy
for somebody that's raised
$10 million and still is burning.
My man, do you know how many
god damn entrepreneurs right now
that are 24 years old
that raised $10 million
have gone skiing the
last four weekends in a row?
The alternative is exactly what's
happened the last 100 years
which is those entrepreneurs were
so scared that they were going to
default on their balance at the bank
that they worked on Saturday.
I can't believe I'm a little
bit under the weather.
This is like rare territory, Vayniacs.
Sucks.
Now, I want to make sure
and this is important to me
and I'd appreciate if you add this,
I want to have a very
strong asterisk and caveat
in parallel there
will be enormously
big businesses built
during this climate
because the internet
is eating up the world.
So much like Amazon and eBay
were built during the Web 1.0 burst,
I very much am bullish on
nternet, consumer web opportunities
I just think that we're
going to have a cleansing
of the tier two, three, four,
five, six, seven and eight entrepreneurs.
It's an absolute
purging of the posers.
That's exactly what's
going to happen. Right?
And, by the way, it's not
because I'm so smart,
it's because that's what always happens
when things get too frothy. You know?
I know this as soon
as you started seeing kids
who never had an
entrepreneurial bone in their body,
who never sold a thing in their life,
who never cared about any of that stuff
and were coming out of
college and starting businesses,
that's when I was like, 24 months ago,
that's when I was like uh-oh,
this is starting to get a little awkward.
I would tell you that I don't
see this as a negative.
I think that's what's great
about capitalism and meritocracy.
Not everybody is supposed
to become a world class singer
or a professional athlete.
The market should have it's repercussions
and, by the way, I think
a lot of these kids
I actually think a lot of
the kids that are getting into it now
are going to be saved
because instead of wasting
four or five years
trying to be a number one,
they're going to go and
work for Bain or McKinsey
or all these other places. Right?
All these practical businesses.
And they'll gain skills, they'll craft
and they'll become more self-aware
and they may learn on the next rodeo
that they're not the number one
but they could be a
tremendous president
or a tremendous CFO
or a tremendous senior executive
and probably find
much more fruitfulness
in playing in the proper
position than the alternative.
And to me, that's what's fascinating.
Everybody knows it to be true
if you're willing to just break it down
in simple conversation.
The problem is we
all got caught up
in the reality of
the game instead
of the reality of
actual business talk.
We're in deep fucking shit and kiltz's
this is not good.
- [Driver] Last two times happened, worse.
- My name is Gary.
Tell him I left him messages
and emailed him that there was a
major accident in New York and
I'm forty minutes late. Four-zero.
Yeah, thank you.
- [Mike] Caesar salad, no dressing--
- [Gary] 'Kay.
- [Mike] and the salmon.
- [Gary] Okay.
You get the message?
Did you get the
message from them?
Okay.
In the hard streets
of Greenwich, Connecticut.
Great meeting, senior execs.
Always fun to break bread
with people that did it
before you at the highest levels.
Now headed back to New York to
jam with some of my senior team.
So, let's do it.
I see Rossini and Chris.
Why don't you guys go get in.
I'm just going to finish right now.
Sup Jace?
- How's it going?
- Good, man.
Wrapping up the day.
My homies. VaynerMedia crew.
Marcus, say hello.
There we go.
Just so you know, grinding,
under the weather,
almost midnight.
Not every day is gonna
come super easy
but persevering, you know, just...
when the buck stops with you
there just isn't a
whole lot of sick days.
Not to say, because I always
get banged for this,
if you're really sick, you should
stay home and rest
but the differnce when it's on you is
when you're borderline sick,
you grind out an 18 hour day.
You know?
Anyway, hope you're well.